this is a production of Cornell
University
so what's a herbarium and herbarium I
don't know British whatever you want
it's a it's a place where we keep dried
plant specimens now I'm going to go
through everything very quickly here and
it's not as funny as most of my talks I
just want you guys to know that it also
includes liquid preserved specimens
mostly most herberia have some but I
think we're kind of moving away from
that because it's a pain oh do I need
the microphone can you guys hear me no
all right sorry about that
can you hear me now
no
yes I have to still screen okay good all
right
um so there are other things that are
included in herberia typically archive
field notebooks Associated literature
and reprints when I first came here we
had a massive reprint collection we sent
most of that off to various places and
now they wish they didn't have it early
herbaria were often established
primarily for the study in medicinal
plants and I'll go ahead and move on
here
so this is the first uh real herbarium
it's uh was by Luka guini an Italian
physician again most herbaria were
connected to Medical Enterprises really
pharmacists medical doctors and so forth
um so we'll move along without much
uh do here but early herbary oftentimes
are often uh we're also bound into books
so this is an example of one from 1603
from the British museum I just got that
online and then this is one of ours
which is his latest this is for around
maybe 1915 of plants from our area here
now
whoa now we put these we put specimens
on herbarium sheets I mean this has been
going on for a long long time and this
is just an example of some of our
documentation of the Geneva experiment
station there those are three uh early
varieties of grape 27 23 and three and
how do we store our specimens if you
guys come to the open house you'll see
this we put our specimens into these big
cabinets which are insect proof insects
are one of the real problems we have in
maintaining her barrier because there
are certain kinds of little beetles and
things that love to eat for various
specimens there's even a species of
beetle that likes to eat the glue that
we glued them on the sheets with
now I just I can't go on without
mentioning some the other collections
that are here at Cornell including the
Plant Pathology herbarium that's it I'm
not talking about it anymore the Cornell
University Museum of vertebrates insect
collections I forgot the brain
collection
okay so what about us we have about 950
000 plus specimens we're not sure it
could be as much as a million uh it's
really until we get it all digitized
database we won't know for sure but
that's an estimate I think it's probably
closer to a million now because we've
been saying 950 for a long time
there are about 250 000 of those
specimens have been digitized
and uh all of our New York specimens
have been digitized the Wild Ones not
all the cultivated species this is uh
Anna and Peter who are in our employees
our staff at the herbarian and I want to
give them a shout out right now because
without them we couldn't have even done
this uh presentation there's a lot of
materials here that they helped assemble
produce uh slides and so forth
speaking of which our herberia actually
represent our herbarium actually
represents the fusion of three
historical herbaria you'll see you
botany herbarium the Wigan turbarium and
then Bailey's uh Barbarian you're not
going to go into any detail here but you
can uh We've now taken this name for the
entire herbarium so we refer to the
herbarium as the Bailey Horton or BH
herbarium and that's the official
acronym in index or beriorum but you
should remember that it is there are
other herbaria that have been infused
into it
what are some of the strengths of our
herbarium each herbarium in the world
has different strengths in other words
different sets of specimens that are
they have a lot of or typically this is
because some worker has been there that
was interested in that group and some of
ours are cultivated plants we have about
000 specimens of cultivated plants and
this is because of the legacy of LH
Bailey we have of course a lot of New
York plants about 110 000 specimens New
York State plants we also have an
incredible Palm collection they're two
really good Palm collections in the U.S
the New York Botanical Garden and the
Bailey oratorium and we have um and I
don't have a number there we forgot to
get the number I apologize Anna how many
do we have
we have a lot
the problem with Palms which you'll see
in a moment is it really difficult to uh
curate store and all that because
they're so bulky we also have the a very
a premier collection of fugacy mostly
Oaks and that came through me CH Muller
who I worked with gave us his collection
so we have a total of about 15 000
specimen of Oats which are mostly from
Mexico and Central America and and the
Western U.S but we also have an
excellent complement of our New York and
Northeastern Oaks that were already here
before we got Mueller's collection and
because of Mueller we have a lot of type
specimens from Oaks of Mexico and
Central America we also have a very
strong collection of rubis you know
raspberries blackberries so forth and so
on Bailey was a rubicologist okay and we
also have a very good collection of
cypressi there are other collections we
have that are really good but these I
just kind of hit some of the high points
here
all right so why are the palms of pain
here's how we have to store The Palms
mostly uh well there are some Palms we
do put on regular Barbarian sheets but a
large number of the Palms are very bulky
in the collections and they go into
boxes they take up a lot of space and
it's difficult to uh photograph them if
you you know it's a whole table to
photograph one specimen and so forth all
right
we also have a very strong bryophy
collection which I almost never look at
right however we do have Jonathan Shaw
who's now an adjunct here and pardon
about
oh he's not an adjunct yet I think he's
going to make it
all right sorry
but anyway Jonathan
um has connections here and he's been
working quite a bit now in our herbarian
on the stagnant collection now you see
we have the opposite of the Palms in
terms of curational issues with uh
mosses mostly Mosses are put into
envelopes envelopes whatever packets and
sometimes we have as many as eight ten
or more on one sheet and sometimes
you'll see them actually in boxes like
that so they're a pain in that okay
we have a pretty good seed collection
it's not huge but it is a nice thing to
reference if you're trying to figure out
say you have a bale of hay and what's in
the hay or something like that you don't
have to go search through the herbarian
you can go look directly at some of the
seeds
so what are the what's the traditional
importance of herbaria mostly in the old
days her very were used pretty much by
plant taxonomists we have plant
identification fluores and monographs
vouchers whereby say I do an anatomical
study I I take a specimen and put it in
the herbarium and Market as used in that
study it's documentation it's a huge
part of making science repeatable
herbaria are in a very very important
part of that is particularly in the
older literature type collections which
are species name references you can get
species distributions like for a flora
or something like that and then there
are a lot of other things that you can
get out traditionally out of a herbarium
we image uh we're in the process of
Imaging our specimens we have about 200
and Oh I thought the number was up there
uh it'll be in a different place we have
about 220
000 specimens image now I'll admit it's
my fault these aren't uh online yet
they'll be coming online in the next
three to six months but I will show you
the the uh
preview of what they will be
fine thank you
now I want to go on and talk about
herbaria in terms of more modern uses
and of course DNA is everything now
right it's not DNA you guys are careful
I didn't put DNA or molecules the title
it wouldn't be here so basically
herbaria can be viewed as a giant
phenotype DNA archive all right so if
you um look at this paper that was done
in 2020
who I know from the Czech Republic they
did some studies and they found out that
the specimens as old as 200 years you
can extract pretty good DNA out of and
it's not how old they are
it's how they were pressed and the
condition they were in if it was fresh
okay so uh Dan I don't have the numbers
up here but Dan has within our herbarium
he's only only been here Dan two three
years
yeah and you've already have 67
specimens I think you've extracted DNA
from didn't you send me that
well no but I mean it's in our herbarian
you send me the number 67. okay let's go
on it doesn't matter yeah
67 000. okay anyway so if we look at
this as an archive
what is that up there
it's not on my screen it's why I
wouldn't see it
yeah uh where's the mouse it's right
down on the fit on the wall
it's on the word vascular where's the
word vascular mode
okay you do it
I can't do it on my own computer
possible you got it yeah see you can't
do it either
all right we got to move on here okay
it's still there
nice
while we're doing this let's talk about
this so worldwide and this number is
more or less correct I think if it was
in the abstract it's probably wrong
there's 397 000 estimated Barbarian
specimens in the world a million million
did I say thousand I meant million okay
397 million herbarian specimens in the
world now that's just specimens and I'll
show you in a moment many of these
specimens have more than one plant on so
the number of potential DNA samples
there is much higher
now you can take a herbarium specimen
and nobody uses a PCR anymore I'm aware
of that but you can get DNA out of it
right many times not always
so as a an archive or a place to keep
DNA with an Associated phenotype that's
directly connected there's nothing
that's cheaper Greener more permanent
and has the phenotype it's it's hard to
imagine keeping your DNA samples in the
freezer for 200 years I think that would
be a little bit too expensive now silica
is a good thing right so probably I'll
talk about a little bit at the end about
how we might modify what we put into the
herbarium
so we'll talk about that
now one of the things that hasn't been
exploited as far as I know there may be
a paper on this or not but if you can
get DNA DNA out of these specimens we
actually have little uh population
samples oftentimes on these specimens so
that's another aspect of it that might
be of interest
so let's go into the metadata right so
that's DNA in the herbarium everybody
kind of knows about that we also have
metadata based research in the herbarium
so for instance herbarium labels have
various kinds of information on them we
can geo-reference those labels to get
localities like that's what we mostly
would be interested in from gdivs
graphico side big bio nifa is the New
York database and the applications of
the the metadata are varied but the most
important one right now for global
climate change is probably Niche
modeling SDM generation
species distribution models okay we can
also though we can do species mapping we
can do phenological studies we can track
invasive plant introductions looking at
the metadata and we can also look at
rare and endangered and extinctive plant
distributions
here's a paper that was um done about
extended specimens using those to study
global climate change and you see their
whole range of possibilities that you
could use herbarian specimens for that
have relevance in the study of Global
Environmental change we don't have time
to run into great detail there
now these other uses that are emerging
again I already mentioned most of these
um these are just some of the papers
that have recently been done that used
for various specimens a newer thing
that's happening is to do isotope
analysis of specimens to look back in
time to see for instance what the CO2
levels were as captured by the plants
there's also of course phenological
studies by that I mean that you can go
back through the herbarian and see if
flowering times have shifted over time
there have been several papers like that
and of course the idea is that flowering
times might get earlier if the climate
is warming
I had a student that graduated a few
years ago and we kind of reversed this
idea the idea for Rob's uh dissertation
was to take the distributions of the
plants and estimate the climate at that
site so you go to a site let's say you
have a hundred plants growing there you
can do a likelihood analysis to say
based upon the the envelope of climate
that you typically find those plants in
you can estimate what the climate is at
that spot and that can be good for
possible work if you if you're not going
back too far in various other
applications
we can also use herberian specimens to
track invasive plants okay for instance
we can find the earliest records of an
invasive plant in a particular area and
if you do that across the whole
continent then you can kind of track how
an invasive plant might have been
introduced and how it's spread when it
was here when it got to New York State
when it got to Tompkins County things
like that that's of course assuming you
have enough herbarium specimens which
you guys need to go out and get as many
as you can and so that we can do this in
the future so here's purple loose Drive
1875 swallow work 1917 and uh Garland
1878. so this is an incredible resource
for understanding how invasive plants
have moved now we also of course we have
genetic data with these
in theory if we can extract the DNA out
of the we can also look at Origins which
part of Europe did this come from or
something like that a lot of these
invasives were due to very limited
introductions so we can tell more or
less how they can where they came from
and this is a very good uh way to do
that
we also have extinct plants in the
herbarium these are four examples that
we happen to have we probably have a few
more uh what can we do with a herbarium
specimen of an extinct plant well of
course it's definitely a record of the
one of the last times that it was seen
if it's late in the you know near when
it went extinct but we also have DNA
that we might be able to extract from
these we can look at the morphology
which we no longer have things like that
yeah I'll just point out that there's a
new kind of uh jargon that's being used
about this very thing called extended
specimens where you have a specimen and
then you have other things that are
associated with that specimen so an
extended specimen Network can have all
kinds of things in it of course you have
the images you can look at the actual
image of the specimen as an extended uh
aspect of it then you have data that you
get off the labels like the metadata so
forth and so on and then you can connect
these things together in your databases
I want to briefly talk about
um our projects and collaborations this
is a slide that Chelsea shared with me
she forgot to put her name on it so our
stuff for respect lab okay so this is
they're doing all kinds of things that
have either a direct connection to the
herbarian or an indirect connection to
those areas now some of these things
they're they're coming out of large
databases of herberian data and some
might be working in a particular
premiere
I'll leave that up for a moment I'm not
going to go over at all
but just suck it all in
here's a here's a slide that we put
together from Joyce who's no longer here
she said that sounds terrible doesn't it
she's at NYU
no wonder with us okay so
but she worked on uh evolution of vines
buying habits and anatomy and so forth
so not only can she document what she's
doing in the herberian with a voucher
specimen but you can actually take
specimens that have been there for a
long time and and get plan Anatomy out
of those specimens right you can take
sections of the stems so if you're
interested oh well does this family or
this plant have a similar Anatomy maybe
it hasn't been looked at you can get it
out of there
I didn't have a picture of Josh sorry
Josh was Josh yeah okay so but Josh is
doing a project in the herbarium that's
a rotation under uh myself and Alejandra
Gandolfo on the
um
trichomes of the bernoulliac now these
trichomes as many of you know have
adaptive significance and that they're
able to take up water into the plant
through the trichomes that are on the
leaves and so forth so Josh is looking
at the distribution of these and the
variation in the morphology anything
else that's good enough okay
so pH also has an ethnobotanical
collection and we're gonna also we're
going to be soon adding another big
ethnobotanical collection it's a 16 foot
trailer
of uh how do you pronounce his number
Krikorian I always want to say corkian
Krikorian who passed away recently that
he collected um ethnobotanical artifacts
in various places around the world has
some beautiful stuff and he's giving it
to us all we have to do is find a place
to put it maybe in the kitchen back
there I don't know anyway
so a lot of the stuff we have is just
things like hats and so forth but we
have other stuff and we have to be
careful about that stuff
all right so other collaborations we
have various collaborations we have
collaborations with the New York
Botanical Garden the Rochester Academy
of Sciences Buffalo Museum uh Brit and
Texas where we're doing a project with
uh an extended specimen Network that
would be plants collected in the
Philippines and then we have images we
images of those that are connected
directly to the plant and you should
have the specimen and images taken of
that exact plant and how many are there
because I
thousands
twenty thousand there you go that's
pretty good
so we have various kinds of connections
there I want to highlight one of them
David Warrior who's in the audience here
stand updated
David is in the audience and he works
quite a bit in the herbarium and so he's
produced a catalog of the vascular
plants in New York and you're going well
beyond that right you're working on a
bigger project here but David
um is a very important part of our
environment
it's great to get free work
all right so then we also have
connections to the Cornell Botanical
Gardens of course you know we're always
involved with Judy's day and this is uh
we also have been documenting over the
years the collections in the botanical
gardens so a lot of the the specimens
that are grown in the botanical gardens
we have Bavarian specimens of those and
you can see uh over time uh what we have
because things disappear at some point
we also have a collaborative project
with towns Peterson which I don't have
the name up here sorry about that in NSF
project that we're involved with that is
uh documenting African plants so they're
digitizing all of the applicant
specimens
and Zach I want to point out Zach is
Eden who was an undergraduate here is
just finished his PhD he's going to
Harvard and he was involved in our
capturing of the images for the African
stuff he was very interested in that
we also have a lot of undergraduate
students that are employed since uh
Let's see we we've had about 70 students
employed in the herbarium over the past
few years and these students do various
things for Imaging to collecting data
and putting it into the database so but
a lot of other things as well
we also have a connection to courses so
this was uh I guess when Joyce was
teaching the class the students usually
make Collections and they interact with
the bavarium
we also have herbarium tours if you go
to the open house you're going to get a
sort of a tour but it won't be a formal
tour but all this stuff we normally have
out on the tour should be there that
Center picture is
this is how it can look sometimes
courses come to have tours staff comes
to have tours and then we oftentimes not
that often but sometimes we have tours
from people outside of Cornell
oh
there we go we also have an active group
of volunteers okay those are just some
of them
um and volunteering helps us quite a bit
but you know it really does a lot for
the people who volunteer many of these
people are retired and it's a it's a
really great thing for them to come in
and they'll oftentimes sit in groups and
they're working on the database or
Imaging or something like that that's a
river there Imaging
we also have an internship we started
the internship a few years ago
um but we had a Hiatus because of covid
and then now that we got money from Tara
at Lurie some of you know who Tara was
and from her uh mother and so now it's a
funded internship this was the first
year of the funded at Larry internship a
summer program and these are the
participants and of course there's
Justin over there who is our TA
now they're already doing the extended
specimen stuff in the internship this is
they we we had them collect they
collected about 500 plant specimens over
the summer but some of what they
collected was in the conservatory so
this is the brownie uh some of you may
know that so we have a specimen of the
Brownie and also images of the brownie
yet those will be connected when we put
everything out yeah
we can't forget the varsity botany Club
okay so the varsity botany Club was
started what last year
last year okay the varsity botany Club
came out of basically the students who
went to Patagonia kind of got together
and I suggested that they have a club
there is the hardest Forum but the
hardest forum is not about wild botany
collecting plant specimens and all that
stuff so it complements the hardest form
it's not competing with it is it
Jonathan you guys have fights or
anything no okay not yet okay
so this is the slide they put together
all the kinds of things they do they've
had several uh lectures already I think
our 100 gave a lecture you've had others
as well and then they've had little
workshops and things like that so it's a
really a great thing
um
yeah we're doing okay so another program
that's kind of associated with the
herbarian is the Patagonia program
that's also a sodium associated with the
Gandolfo lab because
Alejandra works on fossils in Patagonia
I've done various things in Patagonia
over the years in terms of research
mostly with north of Vegas the Southern
Beach so we had this connection and a
few years ago Dean um
Henry
came to Bill and said can anybody teach
a class that gets the students involved
in uh
Hands-On body and so I said well I've
been planning on teaching a vegetation
class anyway out of that grew the
Patagonia field trip and then Mrs Lynch
who's got lots of money gave us money to
do this and it's been recurrent we've
now been doing it I think this is the
12th time we'll be taking students this
January so this is a typical route that
we might take we sometimes go into Chile
other times not we in the past few years
when boys ended up here at the huge
Glacier in the burrito Moreno which is a
life-changing experience there it is up
there for a lot of people we've never
seen a massive Furniture close it's
pretty interesting so now we have other
collections in the herbarian over the
years I have
um kind of rescued things and then we
also developed an image collection so
I'm going to talk a little bit about
those things coupak which I'll talk
about in a moment Cornell University
plan Anatomy collection is a collection
of anatomical slides cubic is a
collection of live plant images mostly
the Horticultural catalog collection pre
predates me and is a collection of seed
and Nursery catalogs many of which are
really beautiful and you'll be able to
see those some of those if you come to
the open house
we also have the Cornell University
paleo Botanical collection and three or
four years ago I kind of negotiated the
bill and Alejandra said let's just pull
this under the umbrella of the herbarian
makes it more secure we can deal with it
in a better way so these things are all
administratively now at a certain level
under the herbarium although the cupc
collection clearly will have a separate
curator the conservatory I'm not
involved at all with uh maintenance or
growing of plants but I and the
herbarian accounts have to do with
replenishing and and deciding on what
plants we have in the conservatory for
research or teaching so you could come
to me as well as Paul who's in the back
there if you have any ideas about some
plants you'd like to see in the
conservatory but again the conservatory
is not about Horticulture per se or it's
it's a teaching and biodiversity
collection really
we also have a lot of archival materials
and we have as I said a little Botanical
artifacts so the crew pack the Cornell
University plan Anatomy collection came
after I over you know I came in 1985 and
over the years I'd say there's these
boxes of slides and anatomical slides
and nobody wants them
so I started collecting those things
together you now have a massive
collection and Maria Gandolfo Alejandra
is a curator we have thousands of online
searchable images I'll give them a
little demo of that supplement what time
do we officially in five afternoon
okay you're fine okay
now here's a little bit of information
about coopac we have a lot of really
important uh plan anatomists from
Cornell and a few from other places
where we have slides many of these
slides have to do with their published
work and we try to connect those up you
might call that an extended specimen
they're vouchers in other words so maybe
Eames did a study of some aspect of
anatomy we have the slides and we also
may have a herbarian specimen who goes
with it we're still in the process of
connecting all this stuff up those are
some of the people that have important
collections look Charlie we've got 14
000 of his slides now of course many of
these slides in these cases are
sequential serial sections so we'll pick
out of those but the slides themselves
will digitize only some of them but the
slides themselves will be available if
somebody wants to live with whole series
let's go into this the cube cubic this
grew out of the fusion of two different
plant image databases one of which I
started which is called plant
systematics.org so I write I wrote some
software to manage uh images and MySQL
databases and do a web interface and
then Dan Nick print contacted me I put a
little thing on the site if you're
interested in this you know so Dan
contacted me quite around
2003 or something somewhere in that area
and so I set him up he started his own
site called Fido images using the same
software and then recently we decided
that we're going to fuse these together
now these were never part of the Cornell
system so now they are that's the whole
point cubic denotes that they're coming
into the Cornell system because Dan and
I aren't going to be here forever so
they have to have some con due going
forward we now have about 220 000 images
in that database
now the cubic is a really important
resource for images
unlike something like I naturalist This
is highly curated in the sense that it's
not just a bunch of pictures that people
take these are oftentimes taken uh with
particular reasons in mind and I'll show
you there we're trying to get the
characteristics of the plants
all right advanced search functions so
forth so on
don't worry too much about that oh here
it is 83
000 images in this project with bread
and that's a big project
right so Dan uses our collection almost
exclusively to develop materials for his
class these images all came out of our
database so prepped in yes okay so you
can see the usefulness and again unlike
a naturalist I'm not dissing I
naturalists don't worry but unlike I
mean these are the kinds of images we
often find images that actually are
zooming in and have detail and they're
keyworded uh most of them when we're
adding keywords so that you can find
what you want
we also have the catalog collection
which I mentioned we have 135
000 catalogs and you'll get to see these
in fact I think this one might be on the
table up there right now but these it
there was a certain period of time when
these were like works of art and um
very nice but we ours ours go back to
the 17 weeks
and here it is this is in the vault
downstairs some of it's in the vault a
lot of it's in the vault some of it's
still up in the herbarium and
truthfully we haven't figured out
exactly what to do with this it's hard
to get money for this because it's
Horticultural and it's not growing
plants years ago I tried to get some
grants
from Horticultural societies and they
didn't they didn't care about the
taxonomy of Horticultural plants and
things like that
now we also
um covid really generated this for us
when covet hit I had to send Anna and
Peter home and we didn't exactly have a
lot that they could do there so I set it
up so that they could start to populate
our biography database so we now have a
biography database of about uh well in
the database we have
3780 people
some of you are probably in there and
don't know it because we only bring the
the biographies public after the person
so
um the point is that we have 2002 that
have passed more or less there's more
now but this is probably one of the best
places you can find information about
female botanists window botanists
and then we also I've categorized these
things and you can search you can get a
list of planet anatomists of uh
daily horitorium Affiliated biography
cornell-affiliated biographies uh we
have 167 paleobots 46
cytogeneticists and so forth
cupc I'm not going to talk much about
this is the paleo collection uh this was
a lot who started it actually built oh
well Banks certainly was thanks was the
big guy but I thought there was some
other stuff there before that yeah the
small teaching collection small teaching
collection all right so we we just
started to deal with this it's it's a
there's a lot of stuff it's difficult
okay so that's for the future bill is
spearheading uh writing a grant to get
an improvement like new cases and
digitization things like that
so now I want to go into the little uh
demo here
oh now I gotta find the mouse there it
is wow
ah
okay everybody close their eyes out
I know that was a joke
all right so I'm just going to take you
now I want to point out this will be the
uh it should be doing that but this is
the new website it's not online yet so
you're going to approve you and you can
see this would be the herbarium
like actually physically okay
well it's okay I can just talked about
it
yeah
all right
can I get it centered there that's good
enough all right so
all right so this is yeah it's all
backwards looks like that so um this
would be the main herbarian site this
will be cubit
and if we scroll down and see now now I
can't I can see it up there maybe
oh wow I've got a mouse up there too
all right there's two pack see your PC
Conservatory the catalog
we also I haven't mention we have a huge
literature database well not huge
relative to Google but during covet as
well I had to have things for Anna and
Peter to do so we started to capture old
literature
so I can show you an example of this we
have about 220
000 items in our literature database we
have Botanical Gazette old American
Journal botany Evolution ecology all
those things I won't tell you how I got
all that stuff
um I could tell you okay so at any rate
uh then we have a bunch of other stuff
but let's go back up
irritating
yeah it's down there oh we don't have
this populated yet well I'll just show
you BH files quickly first okay here's
VH files this is public if you want to
go there you can go through it there is
the
URL up there if you want to write it
down and today
we have more on this date which it gives
you if you go to the site
um
my favorite guy lysenko was born today
and Francis Marion omby isn't he your
grandfather or something
no no no
who's Heiser uh Baker Baker so it wasn't
on me I thought okay so only was really
important in uh polyploid uh studies and
so forth lysenko we're going back to
lysinko soon after the next national
election
so at any rate but you can see for
instance we have women in botany here
and you can click on that I think we
have 406
women in botany here
and I think it's relatively complete the
way we did this is we started by taking
our database of specimens and then
making
biographies uh entries on everybody who
had collected so we have a lot of people
here that you won't find in other places
and then we continue to add to it all
right so if you click on one of these
you can get
uh more information it varies quite a
bit and if any students or anybody
here's the problem we have I every time
we hire a student I say are you
interested in history do you want to
work on the biographies
sip the students do not are not
interested in history or biographies or
anything like that at this point
okay but for instance let's go down
uh
see if there's anybody there is
ah okay you guys can visit that as you
see fit but it's extremely useful you
know so now again we don't have
living people in this we have plant
Anonymous support and so on so now let's
go back
and I can show you if we go back up
right
well let's just go to coupak so this
coupon has not been updated this is a
public site this is not the public site
URL but you can find it pretty easily
all right so this will be the new one
now I want to point out this is not the
launch thing so we don't we're going to
put putting backgrounds and colors on
this you're seeing the basic thing that
has a functional whoa that's nice
I remember that okay so then we come
here
and also we can search
and you guys could know about something
these are anatomical features
so if I
do this
did I misspell it yeah no I didn't okay
so Sif cells
I don't know who put that in there right
that's not what I wanted to show you so
let's go back
so what I do want to show you though is
that you can measure
well that's not Anatomy
it'll be in there let's do it
all right so here's a whole bunch of
trade kids
we click on here we can actually measure
energies here now one of the problems is
I'm going to make is multiple colors
it's red so
there we go that didn't work because you
didn't see it see it's no good on red
I'm going to make it so that the
measurement lines are different colors
here's the green let's look at that
we'll see it more easily
uh because I have to go to the other one
measurement all right so you can come in
here and you can measure these things
obviously so that's one point
142 micrometers you can save the the
measurements up here
you click on that
all right so they come up here
um I also have a setting that's not for
the public that I can load them into a
database directly so one of the
questions we're getting ready to do this
and I'll show you with the plant Smith
does our Barbarian specimens will come
back here
this is hard guys sorry
so if we come back up here you can see
that we have
searchable database here so of course
we'll put in my favorite jeans here now
again all of this was not ready to go
public yet so it will be very soon one
of the things that I've really made an
effort to do is make it fast that's the
first time that was loaded on this
computer so it's not cached anything all
right so you see that it's very fast
and then um it also
I mean I've looked at a lot of the
online specimen databases and I find
them to be a little bit confusing this
is very simple and straightforward but
if we want to
measure a specimen you can come here now
this screen is not very good but you can
say let's say you wanted to measure
the width of bats that that leaf so
there again it's the same thing that's
nine centimeters and then I can load
that up and so if you're doing it not
through my database you can still just
paste your values
okay so let's go back we're about done
yes perfect
um so we want to go to cubic
cubic is very impressive
and I have to give Dan and our other
collaborators a lot of credit on this
it's myself Dan Peter Pelzer
mihai costea is that I said and
um Julie Barcelona uh various other
people that are involved in this so we
have 232
000 integers
so this is the one I like to do because
it's so impressive
you guys familiar with Ruby AC
ID oh look how I spelled that sorry
okay yeah
all right I think it'll still work we'll
find out
so then I can search stipuls
right no it doesn't like it
no it doesn't need any oh sorry guys
what it needs is to not have it must be
case sensitive
so we're going to come back here
and hopefully
you never know there could be a glitch
here but I hope not for the AC stick
field there you go see how quick it
loads
okay so that actually has
372 images
of Ruby AC stipulates
right that's just one of the pages there
and see so we're we're making an effort
to make comparable images
across the data uh our image size here
and that's it I've got to quit
so oh no I don't have to quit I have to
go to the next slide
and so what's the Neo herbarian okay so
we have a new paradigm that extends the
concept of specimen that I think I I
hopefully I made that clear and not only
in terms of the actual specimen but the
metadata that's involved
combines links to multiple aspects of
plant biology in a digital framework
it recognizes the value of the Neo
Barbarian of the herbarium is a global
Archive of genotype phenotype data
they're going to be undoubtedly new and
unanticipated uses as well and I think I
I can't under uh emphasize that this the
herbarium has become a hub for
undergraduate students right clear yes
the undergraduate students are always in
and out of there and it became the
center for the the club as well
so adapting her bearing practices to New
Uses I forgot to put perhaps we should
always try to get silica samples but one
of the things is just to dry without
heat or minimal heat to try to get it
maybe a specimen plus a population
sample DNA conscious collecting and
databasing labeling in the field using I
already have software that does this but
it's not quite ready to go out and then
we're also going to propose that the
herbarium could be a service for any of
you guys who don't really care to
refresh your plants let's say you do an
experiment you want to document it you
can bring the plants to us
and then we can press them and put them
in the herbarian and they'll be there
for
200 years 500 years but you can incite
those specimens if anybody has a
question about what you're working on
thank you
try a little lower any questions
no plus ready this is such a completely
that says
front sections of trees
I've never seen that and there's you can
do anything
well the other thing is if you document
and say out the tree Maybe
you can look at isotope Isotopes later
when I get population sentences the main
thing though I think that we have
already are these small population
samples that nobody as far as I come so
you can look at you know what's the
variation we've got 10 plants from a
site from 1925 and the things now
extinct was it you know inbred or
whatever so
um
yes that's it
why why are barbarians
because of DNA
no I mean in space
you know every square foot plus
something every person you hire Plus
right and so since the trend has been to
go more to molecular studies I think for
Mary had been viewed it's not that
important to the general Trend in plant
biology and other areas trying to make
the point here that that doesn't need to
be it should
that means it's all a cost benefits
you know and the other thing is what
happens is if there's a higher sometimes
you know there was a very impurator and
then when they hire they hire somebody
who has nothing to do with it
could send the herbarian off somewhere
like that happens as well
following up on the sending or very
Advanced
um based on your experience you already
touched on some of this in the top
what is the value of keeping herbaria
especially at academic institutions
because you know we could send it to
nybj and send it to Bill Bob but we have
this undergraduate population and that
opportunity for exposures but
first for for
yeah absolutely undergraduate
participation teaching
experience is is a huge thing now does
that justify having a 950 000
specifically probably not
but um I also think that most people who
are doing research even now could
benefit from documenting their specimens
to positive and preparing it's a
permanent record that's what science is
about right repeatability so if you do a
study and you just say this was
philictrum whatever
right if you say that's what it was
everybody has to take your word for it
if you make a voucher then somebody can
go back and check it that's that's one
of the major uses of barbariance why
they shouldn't all be in one place is
probably a matter of the administration
and
nuclear war it's better to have them
dispersed you laugh at that but CH
Muller we got no uh collection from he
actually thought very carefully about it
before he gave it to us
he's really Old Navy so you know I've
considered it and I think Cornell is not
going to be likely to be hit
he didn't want to survarian to be in New
York City
yeah all right
okay thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu